this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and in
this episode jonathan's back with the
call of duty franchise this time taking
a look at the weapons from cod 4 modern
warfare remastered i'm going to be over
using the word iconic i think in this
video the iconic barrett m82 a1 the
claimed distance of over 800 meters that
does not look like 800 meters plus in
that scope to me if you want to see more
of jonathan's take on call of duty make
sure to check out our back catalogue
with them all you can find a link to the
playlist in the description of this
video and if there are any other games
guns and mechanics you guys want to see
jonathan break down let us know in the
comment section right let's take a look
at the guns of call of duty 4 modern
warfare
this is a remake of course or a
remaster so we have the same pump action
shotgun as the original game i'm not
actually sure why they went with the
winchester model 1200 necessarily no
reason not to games typically default to
the remington 870 uh the mossberg 500.
so to have the winchester is was
a bit of a different choice it's well
done um the fact that you can see
through through the ejection port and
see the cartridge lifter and the
cartridge is being inserted it's all
it's all very well done but kind of
unremarkable the pump action is a pump
action and the modern warfare pump
action is still the modern warfare fun
faction just in glorious hd
all right now credit to irregular dave
for spotting this before i spotted this
i have to give you to give you the shout
out so 50 rounds in this translucent
plastic magazine which is otherwise
really nicely modelled that might be i
don't want to offend any other
developers but that might be the best
p90 magazine i've seen it's got a
functioning spring and follower and all
of that however the rounds are all
already fired because they've modelled
fired rounds rather than making the
primer flush yep we're being picky but
it is it is there it's a good p90 what
can i say the texture on the polymer is
really good that's something that's
often overlooked and then how you like
that is also really important to stop it
looking
metal basically and we can see the
contrast between the it's not really a
carry handle but the sight to the sight
mount where it's got sort of edge worn
metal it looks worn in the right places
and then where that meets that polymer
receiver is it's really good what can i
say um i think it's especially good
considering this is not scratch built
they are working with presumably
existing assets to at least some extent
overall it's good you've got the it
really does give you that i mean
fortunate enough to fire a p90 this it's
super controllable and you get the sense
of being able to keep all of your shots
on target even if in reality i probably
couldn't
but you get that sense from the from
this version quite nicely so close
quarter combat weapon particles if i can
sound very silly in using terrible
english french
g36
this one is a an x uk police example
semi-automatic only but it's suitably
tricked out for roughly this era at
least when the original
modern warfare came out it is the g36c
compact anyway main reason for actually
getting hold of one is the reload in
this is interesting now the conventional
the g36 magazine while it's modular and
you can get an ar-15 style one with a
magazine catch where my finger is that's
not super common and this is the
traditional version so is this
with a paddle release
like that now the paddles modeled on the
gun in game it's either fudged and he's
not operating the magazine capture tool
or he's using his index finger for
whatever reason so he's going from the
trigger to the paddle
pushing up
it does it's not not visible from this
side
and then replacing the magazine like
that but i don't see the catch move i
think it's probably not and they're just
kind of glossing over it but it's it's
excusable because from the side we see
the gun
you can't see it really anyway
m16a4
correctly modeled visually as an m16a4
but it is firing on automatic cannot
remember if it did in the original game
or not but yeah it should be three round
burst and that really quirky three round
burst system where if you only fire one
your next burst is only two or if you
fire a burst of two your next your next
burst is one round uh much complained
about by various soldiers and people
like me now something that i think has
carried over from the original game is
that
weirdly tall rear sight and probably the
aperture is wrong as the the rear sight
apertures on virtually all the guns in
the game are not right but i think
that's a deliberate design choice and
probably so is this very tourist site
now why do i care about that well if you
were to drop this in the field those
site protectors either side of the site
are not protecting it and it's not like
the garand where you can crank the site
up and away from its protectors
this would just be there permanently
right now we're in multiplayer the gun
is working in three round burst now the
way mouse and keyboard or controller or
whatever it works and i guess just
because it would be a pain in the in the
back side if they modeled the real
three-round burst function it is three
rounds every time you pull the trigger
you're not going to be able to let off
the trigger and stop it at one or two
rounds out of the burst which for the
sanity of the player i think is a good
choice enemy transport cited entering
the target area
it's now or never take the shot
target is down nice shuffle it
shut that on to us take out that
helicopter you'll buy us some
time gonna be over using the word iconic
i think in this in this video
the iconic barrett m82 a1 anti-materiel
rifle used of course in modern warfare
to blow what's his face's arm off
there's your first problem well well you
can't blow someone's arm off with
a rifle well maybe a 20 millimeter rifle
the claimed distance of over 800 meters
that does not look like 800 meters plus
in that scope to me even if you've got a
20-pound scope everything should look a
lot smaller than that any long-range
shooters in the comments please feel
free to
to chime in i've only ever fired beyond
1000 yards once and that was with a
cheaty rifle with a guided trigger
so the rifle itself is
everyone knows the barrett of course
this one is
basically identical to whoops wrong side
our one behind there only difference is
this has a strip of picatinny rail
screwed to the sight mount ours has the
old-fashioned weaver rail later variants
do have a continuous strip of picatinny
rail across the top of the receiver but
for the school m82a1 which is pretty
much is it's well done
quick pause just to say taking around a
50 bmg in the back even if you're
wearing ballistic plate or whatever not
a good time um you're not gonna get
blown down the street but uh depending
what the armor is you might maybe no you
probably are dead it's probably
certainly gonna go through whatever
you're wearing and the back face
deformation is going to be significant
so even if it didn't penetrate somehow
it would absolutely mangle you so that
npc there who took a hit fall to the
back really a weapon like this in in any
kind of vaguely reporting to be a
realistic game should be a one-hit
incapacitation even if it's not a
one-hit kill and then offset that by
making it hard to aim or something
wow that was
very rapid now if you go
mooching around youtube you'll find
clips of shall we say some absolute
units firing missing rapidly from the
shoulder not all of them are like a
massive um jerry michelette absolute
legend rapid fires these things from the
shoulder based on technique and a
minimum level of strength of course
upper body strength and hits targets
with them but he's doing it at very very
close range that's some michelette level
trigger control
there almost any other scenario i would
be raising an eyebrow at that this thing
is surprisingly capable at closer ranges
shall we say but it's not its purpose
it's not what it's trained to be used as
and it isn't so i know operationally
used that way but hey this is
essentially an interactive action movie
another iconic military weapon and an
iconic cod weapon as well um the m40 so
the as far as i know the m40 is still in
use so this is the us marine corps
modified
era this is the a3 correct from 2007-ish
their upgraded version of the quite
venerable now remington 700. it's still
correctly depicted reloading from the
top not from a detachable magazine i
think the current variant the a5 has
moved to the pretty ubiquitous
ubiquitous now detachable magazine so
you do most of your loading using the
box magazine but here we are feeding
individual rounds in from the top of the
action which is how the a3 did operate
but then it was broadly correct in the
original game so i'd be surprised if
anything changed since then i'm not
familiar enough with the correct scope
for the a3 we don't have one
unfortunately to know whether the scope
reticle is correct it looks like a
pretty standard mill dot type reticle
which of course in the game doesn't
really mean anything you can try to use
the um hash marks to aim off or aim over
hold over but it's going to be radically
different than it it would be on the
real rifle
um something i did notice that's new on
this and a couple of other models uh the
player the animation the reloading
animation checks the chamber does a
press check we don't commonly see that
done with sniper rifles but um having
once uh used a long-range rifle where
the bolt did not pick up the round from
the magazine like it's supposed to it
might be very very rare that it doesn't
happen it doesn't happen but i can sort
of see why people use these things for
real might want to perform a chest but
that is quite a modern trend in shooting
techniques
mp5sd i should have saved my use the
word iconic for this really
as a real gun and in the call of duty
games i've managed to put together for
this
session from bits the configuration that
we see in the game which is the mp5 sd
a3 so it's the retractable butt stock
that means we've i've also added on to
what was originally the oldest style of
trigger group on this gun the more
modern style of slick sided as it were
mp5 trigger pack and it's the standard
safe semi auto um something you'll
notice on the on the cod mp5 is that it
appears to sit between the two settings
which wouldn't be a good idea because
you wouldn't quite know which one it was
actually pointing at as it were so
whether when you pull the trigger
whether you're going to get automatic or
single charge now that's probably
because somewhere in the design process
this was going to be an mp5 navy trigger
group which has a three round burst
setting between those two um we've got a
nice view of well this is empty but um
rounds in the magazine and they look
really nice they're positioned correctly
they're nicely modelled both of which
were not true in former games and i
thought probably also true of the
original unremastered version of this
game
and disappointingly we do not get the hk
slap i have to i have to point out that
there is now music video of the hk slap
you can find it if you look for it it's
very niche but highly amusing so the
standard reload on this is
change the magazine
operate charging handle now the cocking
handle if you will that does work but
the problem has always been and this is
why it's in the hk manual might not be
in your drill manual depending which
army you serve with but um because of
the spring pressure and the rounds
sticking proud of the feed lips if you
do that
you might not get the magazine on and if
you do you might have trouble uh trouble
chambering the first round hence
you are supposed to lock it open in the
slot change your magazine
and then either push the charging handle
out of the way or burn the manual
slap it
can go down report
another upgrade for this version of the
mp5 mp5sd which is of course the
suppressed version and i think the sound
effect does does kind of get that across
it's not whisper quiet but it's pretty
damn quiet something else i noticed is
we have a definite two-tone effect
between the polymer lower which is
inevitably a bit of a grayish looking
color versus the flat but slightly shiny
matte black of the
coating on the receiver and we see that
in the game i remember the original gun
being basically just all black
standby
thanks for watching guys those were the
guns again of modern warfare remastered
this time we really appreciate you
watching these videos we are a museum so
if you'd like to support us there you
can go to our website and find out how
to do that whether that's visiting or
dropping us a bit of money we also have
quite a few social media outlets and we
have our own youtube channel fairly
heavily featuring me so if i haven't
pulled you to death please do come and
join us over there as well either way
we'll see you again next time
[Music]
you